on en parlait en début d'émission les
inscriptions débutent aujourd'hui sur la
plateforme parcoursup les lycéens
doivent formuler leurs vœux
d'orientation d'ici le mois de mars avec
nous pour en parler ruddish à Soko
bonsoir
est-ce que vous m'entendez
vous êtes alors vous êtes commercial
plus immédiat pour le magazine
l'Étudiant avec nous également Séverine
delaverne bonsoir alors vous êtes la
directrice de l'école d'ingénieur egio
basé à Vélizy-Villacoublay nous sommes
aussi à Marie Emma boursier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes aussi connectés à
distance avec nous vous êtes
vice-présidente de la Commission
Formation et vie universitaire pour
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors première
question plutôt pour ruddish à Soko sur
parcoursup un nouveau moteur de
recherche plus intuitif a été mis en
place cette année pour pour faciliter
l'information et que ce soit plus clair
pour les étudiants est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne
c'est à moi que vous allez poser la
question
alors pour parcoursup pour le coup donc
la phase d'inscription commence
aujourd'hui donc les étudiants vont
pouvoir faire 10 choix d'abord 10 choix
de formation initiale et ensuite et
aussi du choix de formation d'alternance
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas de hiérarchisation réellement de
leur choix c'est d'avoir un peu ils
doivent choisir un peu ce qui leur
plaisent qu'ils veulent et donc pour les
aider on a le salon qui aura lieu ce
week-end au Vélodrome pour les guider
dans dans leur choix d'orientation et
donc plusieurs formations qui ont été
ajoutées c'est une nouveauté cette année
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus quels sont quelles sont ces
formations nouvelles sur la plateforme
alors pour le coup les formations en
elle-même nouvelle j'en ai pas le nom
mais il y a 20 000 formations en tous
parcoursup et pour tout et chaque chaque
formation est bien documentée donc
chaque
qui sont présents sur parcoursup
documente donc pour le coup
je pourrais pas vous donner le nom des
formations mais vous avez un gros panel
de formation sur le sur le parcoursup
alors comment est-ce que ça fonctionne
on rentre une formation mais il me
semble que sur un vœu on peut le
catégoriser le déplier en plusieurs vœux
alors je vous avoue que je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas toutes ces informations
clairement par parcours et la procédure
mais par exemple sur le salon de
Saint-Quentin Yvelines ce week-end on a
une formation qui sera présentée par
l'académie de Versailles qui explique la
procédure en détail et vous pourrez
avoir du coup ces informations sur salon
ce week-end Séverine delave peut-être
que vous avez juste préciser
qu'effectivement il y a 10 vœux et il y
a 20 sous vœux et en fonction de la
catégorie des vœux il y a des
universités ou des écoles qui sont
regroupées notamment les écoles
d'ingénieurs sont regroupées et donc
souvent le sous vœu correspond à un
souveux et pas plusieurs sous vœux voilà
donc c'est un petit peu technique mais
il y a au moins 10 vœux et 20 sous vœux
à sélectionner en fait voilà et donc
vous le disiez à l'instant on me dit à
Soko il va y avoir le Salon de
l'Étudiant ce sera ce samedi 21 janvier
qu'est-ce comment est-ce qu'on peut se
préparer pour pour aller à ce salon
est-ce qu'il y a des choses à préparer
en amont
alors
première chose le salon est totalement
gratuit donc on a une plateforme hybride
donc une plateforme en ligne le salon en
ligne il faut passer par cette
plateforme là pour s'inscrire et donc
cette année nous avons mis en place en
fait cette plateforme afin d'aider les
visiteurs à préparer leur donc leur
parcours et donc leur choix
d'orientation donc quand ils arrivent
sur la plateforme ils ont la liste des
exposants la liste de nos conférences et
donc qui peuvent donc déjà contacté
certains des exposants et les ajouter à
leur parcours de visite pour que en
arrivant sur le salon aller les
rencontrer directement et avoir toutes
les informations en fait en amont et
donc la plateforme elle est ouverte
qu'un jour avant elle était déjà ouverte
depuis début janvier et elle fermera à
trois jours après le salon donc le 24 le
24 janvier
avec les exposants
Marie Emma boursier l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sera présente au salon de l'étudiant
le seul acteur public universitaire de
secteur de ce territoire donc nous
sommes évidemment présents avec une
offre de formation très large puisque
nous sommes une université
pluridisciplinaire avec des composantes
qui ont des sciences dures aussi
management etc donc on est
traditionnellement présent sur sur
voici Séverine delavin vous serez
présente au salon pourquoi c'est
important pour les écoles les
universités d'être présent au Salon de
l'Étudiant alors c'est d'abord d'aller à
la rencontre des potentiels candidats et
de les renseigner surtout sur par
rapport à leur parcours leur choix de
parcours voilà c'est important pour eux
d'avoir le bon niveau d'information pour
saisir justement d'un parcoursup
la formation qui leur correspond le
mieux parce que un jeune qui va sur une
formation qui ne connaît pas ou qui qui
lui plaît pas forcément réussira pas
forcément alors que il a un bon niveau
donc le choix de la formation et crucial
en fait il faut que vous les aidez à
choisir leur formation à les aiguiller
alors nous à le zéro on va effectivement
on a les salons les journées portes
ouvertes voilà on va à la rencontre on
va aussi dans les lycées pour leur
expliquer déjà ce qu'est le métier de
l'ingénieur parce que c'est un métier
qui est pas forcément bien connu enfin
on entend parler du métier d'ingénieur
mais pour un jeune ils comprennent pas
exactement ce que ça implique derrière
donc on leur explique déjà ce qui est le
métier de l'ingénieur et ensuite en
fonction de leur appétence pour les
sciences par exemple on va pouvoir les
aiguiller sur un tel ou tel domaine ou
alors vers d'autres types de formation
donc le conseil qu'on fait nous au sein
de de Zéo enfin il est assez large en
fait c'est à dire que si on voit à part
venir à notre rencontre des jeunes qui
se cherchent etc on pourra aussi leur
donner des bons conseils pour aller vers
d'autres formations qui leur
correspondraient plus en fait c'est ça
qui est important c'est d'avoir un vrai
projet un vrai choix par rapport à une
formation et alors durant le Salon de
l'Étudiant il y aura aussi des
conférences
redishoko c'est aussi un moyen pour pour
aider les étudiants à trouver leur voie
oui en effet les conférences elles sont
faites pour ça c'est un peu l'objectif
aussi de ce salon c'est de pouvoir en
fait mettre toutes les informations à
disposition des étudiants et des
étudiants pour qu'ils puissent faire
leur bon choix donc comme je vous disais
juste avant on a l'académie de
Versailles qui fera une conférence sur
parcoursup on a aussi
l'université qui freine conférence et de
même on a notre rédaction qui est aussi
enfin qui fait des conférences donc en
tout cas sur leurs interrogations liées
à parcoursup et
sur le panel de formation qui peuvent
avoir dans le dans la localité dans tout
ce qui est local local à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ils auront les
informations sur le salon et via les
conférences et on l'a compris il y aura
une conférence sur parcoursup pour
expliquer comment fonctionne la
plateforme quels seront les autres
thèmes des conférences
alors on a donc l'université qui va un
peu parler de comment entrer à
l'université on a aussi des une forme
une conférence sur les formations au
métier de management commerce et de
gestion aussi une autre conférence sur
BTS but un peu comment choisir sa
filière après le bac et une conférence
sur les études scientifiques et
technologiques pour un peu balayer la
totalité des secteurs Marie Emma
boursier du coup on a compris il y aura
une conférence sur et comment entrer à
l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quelles sont
quelles sont les changements quand on
entre à l'université est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
sur cette conférence bien sûr alors
peut-être déjà une précision au fond on
reçoit des étudiants dans ce type de
salon comme dans nos journées portes
ouvertes qui se dérouleront le 4 février
prochain qui ont déjà quand même une
idée de leur orientation ne serait-ce
que par leur origine de filière du bac
et je crois que ce qu'on peut leur
apporter dans ce genre de rencontre
c'est de
la spécificité de l'université à
l'université sa spécificité c'est
qu'elle assure avec les enseignants
chercheurs une double mission une
mission d'enseignement mais sur
l'enseignement qui est appuyée sur sa
mission fondamentale sa seconde mission
fondamentale qui est une mission de
recherche et c'est tout ce que l'on peut
apporter à nos étudiants de nourrir les
enseignements qui leur sont délivrés par
la recherche alors avec un contexte un
contexte très très différent de ce
qu'ils ont connu au lycée et ça fait
partie des questions qu'on a très très
couramment lorsqu'on se déplace dans les
lycées et on est au contact des
bacheliers plutôt bacheliers dans ces
salons beaucoup d'interrogations sur les
modalités des cours entre les cours
magistraux les travaux dirigés la vie
étudiante donc c'est un changement mais
qui est aussi une étape évidemment dans
la vie d'étudiante je crois que le
présupposé la réussite étant un choix en
adéquation avec les capacités et le
souhait évidemment de les alors est-ce
que et alors est-ce que la crise
sanitaire a eu un impact dans le choix
d'orientation des étudiants est-ce que
vous avez remarqué une différence entre
avant et après covid
dans le choix d'orientation des
étudiants non par rapport au chiffre
parcoursup c'est-à-dire on demande que
nous avons qui dépendent en fait des
filières il y a des filières notoirement
sous tension et puis d'autres dans
lesquelles il y a un petit peu loin de
un petit peu moins de pression
il y a la crise du covid on a vu les
résultats en revanche sur l'implication
et les difficultés des étudiants qui qui
ont commencé leurs études et de rentrer
dans le enseignement supérieur l'année
du covid ça a été très délétère pour eux
puisque il y avait la difficulté de
l'approche à distance pour laquelle nous
étions voilà dans une position assez
compliquée et puis l'absence de vie
étudiante parce que tout le l'agrément
c'est aussi ça il y a les contraintes de
l'autonomie et puis son agrément aussi
autour d'une vie de campus qui à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines par les Saclay
et particulièrement développé avec vie
associative étudiante très riche et
beaucoup plus dans lesquels nous
étudiants peuvent aussi
s'épanouir Séverine delaverne je vous
vois au chier de la tête c'est aussi
quelque chose que vous avez remarqué
avec le covid effectivement les élèves
sont enfin en tous les cas voilà ceux
qui sont passés par cette crise là sont
moins bien préparés à l'enseignement
supérieur et effectivement tout ce qui
touche la construction même de
l'individu l'autonomie et les les
savoirs aussi enfin les connaissances
techniques qui peuvent avoir
ne sont pas forcément très consolidés
donc ça veut dire que voilà nous en tant
qu'école on met en place aussi un
accompagnement personnalisé pour pouvoir
aider ces élèves là qui par moments sont
un peu en difficulté voilà pour qu'ils
puissent réussir en fait sur leur
parcours et bien merci beaucoup Ruddy à
Soko et Marie Emma boursier d'avoir
accepté notre invitation